this morning u.s and nato troops began
pulling out of afghanistan
the longest war in american history cost
more than two trillion dollars and tens
of thousands of lives
more than 2400 u.s service members were
killed during the nearly 20-year
conflict in more than 20 000 wounded
late friday 21 people were killed and as
many as 90 others injured in a suicide
truck bombing in afghanistan
there's no indication the attack was
connected to the troop pullout
charlie dagetta is in the afghan capital
of kabul
with the latest
the car bomb south of kabul struck
outside a hostel
afghan officials say high school
students are among dozens dead
part of a surge in violence since
president biden announced he would
extend the u.s
troop pull out beyond today's previously
agreed deadline
the taliban are on war footing vowing to
ramp up attacks across the country
the afghan military has been eager to
show they're ready for the fight
u.s trained forces conducted military
exercises
at a commando training camp outside of
kabul the country's top general yasin
zia told us
his forces have no choice but to be
ready
we receive enough training we receive
enough
experience we we work with the great
generals with great experience
officer the departure of u.s troops and
nato allies comes at a time when a
resurgent taliban
has been at its strongest in the two
decades since being toppled after 9 11.
the streets of kabul are no stranger to
bombings and assassinations but has
largely been out of reach
of major taliban offensives but given
the taliban's gains in the past couple
of years
there are now fears it may eventually be
within their sights
the conflict has cost the lives of more
than 2 400
u.s servicemen and women more than 20
000
injured and the death toll among afghans
more than
60 000 members of the security services
nearly twice as many civilians america's
longest war may soon be coming to an end
here
but afghanistan's war is not over and
the departure of international forces
may open
a new more turbulent chapter in this
country's
bloody history the commander of american
forces here general scott miller has
said that pull-out
is already underway the white house is
warned that should any potential
adversaries attack
we will defend ourselves with all the
tools at our disposal
charlie dagetta for cbs this morning
saturday
in kabul we appreciate charlie and his
team taking us right there to the front
lines of a war
too many folks are forgetting that
people are sacrificing their lives
to fight in